having access to Affordable Health Care
is crucial but a large portion of
students in North Las Vegas aren't able
to get the care they need a
collaboration between the school
district and UNLV is now allowing some
to get medical help as 8 news now
Victoria Saha reports they don't have
far to go
in the Northeast part of town many
Working Families Are faced with barriers
we're able to see that it was a
community in need
into need of Health Care 80 percent of
the kids are more that we see are
uninsured pediatric nurse practitioner
Pamela gergis says the closest
pediatrician is more than six miles away
in this area for me it's heartbreaking
for families without transportation that
can be tough thanks to a donation to
UNLV Health a pediatrician's office is
now in the heart of the community at
Bailey Middle School when we see the
kids we're able to check their ears and
then provide a full physicals and it's
free another benefit of having a health
clinic on site is that parents don't
have to leave work to take their child
to the Doctor Bailey Middle School
students can be seen at the clinic and
then go right back to class we have a
high aquatic absenteeism rate and to try
to cut that down we now have an option
where students can be seen here in March
the clinic expanded by opening its doors
to Hickey Elementary and sunrise High
serving a total of 5 000 students
offering everything from immunization to
lab testing to Mental Health Services
have you seen students that have come in
with conditions that have worsened
because they didn't have access to
health care absolutely asthma is a
really important one that we see because
a lot of kids don't come in into their
really sick or wheezing and that could
have totally been prevented Victoria
Saha eight news now
parents do have to give consent before
their child can be seen at the clinic
UNLV has another free health clinic for
all CCSD students located near Maryland
and Oakey